we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this kind of
bummed me out i've been getting a lot of
emails and voicemails like this here's a
caller in despair over climate change
take a listen hey david i call today
because i just wanted to know if there
was a way for the youth particularly
myself and teen and college students in
particular to get over feelings of
hopelessness in regards to climate
change under trump's america because by
the time a lot of us are old enough to
run it'll be too late to really do
anything substantial thank you well the
show have a good day
i get it i mean it's that we every day
that we don't work towards a solution on
climate change is now two days we need
to undo worth of damage if that makes
sense so i really don't know what to say
I share your despair and of course we've
got a vote we've got to vote them out
the Republican Party is not just the
only party in the United States
prominent party that rejects the science
on climate change it's the only
prominent party in any western country
that rejects the reality of climate
change and I would even argue in
developing nations you don't really have
serious prominent parties that say now
we just don't believe it it's a hoax so
I wish I didn't share your despair but I
do and beyond voting and encouraging
states and municipalities and cities to
do what they can we've got to vote them
out and we are running out of time
that's just the reality I'm also out of
time to tell you what's on today's bonus
show but it's a good one become a member
become a patron for at least five bucks
a month we will speak to you then the
show doesn't have to end right now
because there is a bonus show every day
for our supporters and I hope to speak
to you then